the Council of the Arts is and we remain
in my opinion one of the most important
legacies of dr. Jerome reason Council
for the Arts at MIT was founded by K
Stratton and Jerry Wiesner Jerry was
totally devoted to the art so that he
picked up the little art committee and
made it into the council for the arts
Jerry was a very strong anti-nuclear
person he was President Kennedy science
advisor and felt that institutions like
MIT were turning out a lot of students
and graduates very high technical
expertise who had a fairly large
probability of destroying the world and
it was very important to get involved in
things that have some sense of humanity
they found that MIT really had
tremendous strength in the arts and that
the arts perhaps we're not getting the
kind of resonance the kind of visibility
they should and ought to have because
they thought of the arts is very much
part of the mainstream of MIT very much
part of the core mission when the
council was created 40 years ago it was
almost unique there may have been one or
two others if its kind where else but at
MIT we like going first the view at that
point which is very strange looking back
is if we're going to do art let's buy
some and put it out on the campus in
retrospect that was brilliant public art
collections on University campuses were
ranked back in 2006 and MIT was in the
top ten and we love showing off this
public art collection
the two most recent pieces acquired was
a niche Kapoor's sculpture which is over
in the Stata Center and check blog Jones
at the Sloan School the grants programs
the most vital thing cam it does over
the course of the years we've given over
a thousand grants away several million
dollars a lot of the money we give
allows these people to get money from
other people probably two to three two
one these grants impacted my work in
ways that I had to think about community
these grants are meant to provide for
interaction between students and faculty
was exposed as justice and this is where
a lot of my work has evolved
the council is very important that it
supports the arts here in many different
aspects and carrying the work of art to
the world and allowing us to develop and
flourish in the Institute so thank you
Kamath support of the MIT museum in the
list Visual Arts Center is another
wonderful dimension we give money to the
BSO so the MIT students could get
tickets there either free or cheap money
to the garden of museums into the MFA we
give money every year to the
artist-in-residence program
all of my interactions with the council
have been student focused we've had
residency's where artists will come in
and work with the ensembles
Joe Lovano is probably one of the
greatest tenor saxophone soloist in jazz
and we were able to get him to come to
MIT
and the students rose to the occasion it
was a wonderful example how when they're
in the presence of a great master they
just lift and lift and lift the
McDermott award was founded by Margaret
McDermott the widow of Eugene McDermott
the founder of Texas Instruments mrs.
McDermott decided after Jean died that
she would like to give an award every
year to artists that are mid-career let
me confess I love Santo Domingo I love
coming home to the guys in Blazers
trying to push little cups of brugal
into my hands and it has attracted
wonderful people junot diaz who we later
recruited to our faculty prominent New
Yorker writer Pulitzer Prize winner
Diller Scofidio two architects who were
unknown at the time they were brought to
campus later became world-class
architects and are among other things
the architects of the ICA in all cases
the people who get the award spend some
time at MIT with the students in some
classes it's like learning baseball from
Babe Ruth
but don't be nervous you know for the
young conductor the Los Angeles
Philharmonic miss Leveaux dudamel came
here to receive the award audience most
recently robert lepage the canadian
theatre I Stroh everything he does it
all with experience we've learned that
we should not force connections we let
them and eventually to three things
seems to go together and go oh there's a
pattern there and so the award has
really evolved from a nice award to an
important intermediate artist award to
one of the highest level awards in the
world kamut has always been an
organization that socially bonds that
goes on trips has wonderful art trips
getting into very exclusive private
galleries we've been to pry we've been
to Berlin we've been der Chicago it's
not at the cutting edge of art it's at
the cutting edge of people I mean you're
meeting very smart people among the most
important reasons one should join Cabot
is you get closer to a truly great
institution of higher learning
at MIT we are very much oriented toward
art at the intersection of science and
technology to find out what can we do
that will change the world the best
works that are developed in our classes
here come from students who are
brilliant people from mathematics
material science or mechanical
engineering art opens their view and
possibilities beyond the problem solving
agenda
kamut has been generous to MIT it is the
single most important sponsor of the
Arts the Council for the Arts at MIT
gives an additional voice to the Arts
it's this kind of nourishment that the
council provides that really makes a
difference in what we're able to do it's
about a concern about what the arts mean
at MIT
you